The Joe Rogan Experience the U.S
government produces more classified
information than non-classified
information
so even if like there's an audit they
could redact everything
yeah and it's just all these different
uh divisions and departments and they
all have their own protocols so just
getting a handle on it is I mean that's
the first thing that has to get done we
have to but not not that we're even
going to get the real information from
there right but um but then there's also
the National Security aspect of it it's
like you know you have to have some
things redacted because you know of
China and Russia like you could just say
that and then yeah that is the phrase
that gets used sure so because they have
a full like clamp down on their
population I mean they they limit the
access to the internet they're they're
in is essentially like china-based like
you vpns are illegal it's like and
they're trying to do that here in
America it's all backwards yeah with the
restrict act that is wild it's getting
it's getting nasty 20 years if you use a
VPN which is hilarious and it's it's
managed by the Commerce Department
unelected bureaucrats are the one ones
see the tick tock's actually not named
in that act right they're just letting
the Secretary of Commerce decide which
apps yeah that's insane it's insane so
um yeah Dan Crenshaw posted about it he
he uh
he thinks it's not that big a deal
because he thinks that you know there's
a lot of Acts that get pushed and then
they never get passed through but what's
disturbing is just the idea the desire
to do this and the fact that imagine if
it did get passed I mean it's just a
[__] full-on assault on Free Speech
yeah I mean it seems to be
getting a toxic stigma connected to did
you see Jesse Waters Grill Lindsey
Graham about it no I didn't oh
he didn't read it but he endorsed it oh
Jesus and it was and he just got
completely called out it was it was
really funny like that should be illegal
if you should not even be able to sign
right something that you haven't read
and they can't read it it's too it's too
long right there's not enough time
there's not enough time that's a lot of
these acts right
oh and they slip a bunch of [__] in
there that's like wait a minute what
about page 485 like what the [__] is
going on there and then like oh oh I'm
gonna read that
yeah I meanwhile it's just like because
it changed discourse in this country
it's going to change what people have
you know the the access that people have
to free speech and communication and I
mean I think a lot of people endorsed it
righteously being concerned about Tick
Tock you know
that's what was so sneaky is you know
they they enrage you to then support
This Disaster yeah um and it's just like
we we can all agree that there's a
problem with Tick Tock and that there's
you know the Chinese government having
access to all of this data is is
problematic
but like we there should be an encrypt
act like
encrypt everything but you can't go
around Banning apps it just doesn't work
it's irrelevant people are going to use
uh vpns I I think this this uh act needs
I don't think it's gonna make it
well I I hope you're right yeah because
more people are talking about a Tulsi
gabbard posted a big thing about it
there's a lot of people that are up in
arms but my concern is if it wasn't for
social media that act which was kind of
ironic right if it wasn't for social
media and people sharing this and
becoming outraged and people discussing
this it would have slipped right through
like the Patriot Act did the Patriot Act
existed in a time where there wasn't
social media and people weren't really
aware of what they were pushing through
until it was too late
yeah I think there's much better
Solutions I mean
did you watch any of the tick tock CEO
getting grilled yes I did okay so yeah
you know that was interesting because
you know he's a pretty he seemed like a
sober guy
um but in his point was well you have to
have consistent standards for other
social media companies too I mean right
face like how do we know that Facebook
and Google just because they're us-based
doesn't mean that they're not giving
data to China we have no idea we have no
idea so that's really the issue we need
to understand what specifically are all
of these apps doing they should be
labeled very specifically
um you know and we're starting to see
some of that happen but the thing is you
can't know with these proprietary apps
because they're just not sharing
anything I think one of the problems
that people have with uh whether any
kind of decentralized
um app like yours or any other d
decentralized uh social media network is
it people immediately go Oh what do I
have to do to do this like Mastodon when
people started using Mastodon and you
get on it you're like what is this
there's so many servers and how do I
know what to join and what what's going
on here like yeah so well mines is
different mines is actually not fully
decentralized we're a hybrid so we run a
centralized infrastructure but we
interface through
delegation delegated cryptographic
events signing we we that's happening in
the background but like our app feels
like
a normal social media app it's different
Mastered on the way that that works is
Federated instances so there's all of
these different instances with different
URLs and there's like 20 people on each
one and you know but there is sort of
some interoperability between the
instances because the you can subscribe
to somebody on another instance from
your instance but it's not fully
decentralized it's Federated and the
problem is that you don't own your
identity so if if one of those instances
goes down you're screwed your your stuff
is is gone within in Noster which is
like an architecturally different setup
and there's other protocols similar to
Noster but it doesn't matter if if the
website goes down you just pop over to
another one upload your your key and all
your stuff is there so and that's why we
like it because it keeps us in check
because our users could can now
basically if we [__] around
they'll bounce and they can take their
stuff
and that's you know because the F the
social graph specifically is the key
because you spend a decade bill you know
getting all these followers
people spend their lives doing this and
then to be able to just get taken out by
YouTube is so devastating and unethical
it's really creepy too because many of
the things they took people out for have
turned out to be true like there was a
lot of things that they were labeling as
disinformation or misinformation which
are 100 proven fact now and people lost
their accounts and there's no recourse
they're not going to reinstate you and
that was a problem also with Twitter
that for the longest time if you said
anything that was contrary to whatever
the narrative was what whether the
government was pushing it or the CDC was
pushing it like anything contrary to
that narrative he would get [__]
they're not back though I will I think
Twitter's making way more progress than
everyone else and I'm look I'm
ultimately a neon fan I'm rooting for
him I think it's vastly improved but
there's chaos currently underway at
Twitter oh sure and and those people
have not all been let back on and I
don't really understand the people that
we don't know the people whose random
Joe schmoe posting a covid study like
has he been LED back on all the
thousands of people that got banned like
well I think he essentially let back on
everyone who didn't do anything illegal
so not Alex not Alex yeah that's true
why yeah well that's a personal opinion
of elon's which I don't agree with at
all yeah because they let Andrew Tate on
right you know it's like that doesn't
mean that he's endorsing Alex to let him
back on right it doesn't I mean because
there's a lot of people that are back on
that are you know
they didn't make that one specific
mistake that Alex made but they've said
some but the mistake that the reason
Alex was banned was because he confront
it was actually for something he did off
Twitter so he confronted this journalist
Oliver Darcy in a line at some event and
he was you know being Alex Jones sort of
ranting at him yeah and then Twitter
said oh you're bullying this guy
and this is like not acceptable behavior
so yeah so you're gonna leave but then
when I remember you know the exchange
with Elon and whoever it was that was
asking asking it was that he hadn't been
let on because of the Sandy Hook stuff
yeah which is not the same that's not
even why he was banned right so
you know it's not easy I I understand
you know the politics of it and he
probably has Tim Cook being like
you know we're not going to advertise if
you have Alex Jones but I don't know
what's going on but it doesn't seem to
me because he could he could win the
argument if he would just let him back
on right and and did you see this crazy
clip of uh of Elon and the BBC guy I did
I posted it today oh you did it was
amazing amazing it was amazing it was
amazing yeah because the guy kept trying
to change subjects and let's move on
like no no no no no no no no no no no no
what what the [__] are you talking about
because that guy thought he could just
say the narrative without specific
examples like give me an example and the
guy had no examples that's most people
who are concerned about this wow this is
like a lot of people that I know that
are famous that like publicly announced
they were leaving Twitter and you know
one of them I really love and I was like
why are you doing I didn't even say
anything to her but I'm like why are you
doing this this is so dumb like you
you're just doing this because this is
the thing that everyone feels like
they're supposed to do hey well
Twitter's kind of [__] now so bye no
it was [__] before it's less [__]
now yeah there are there people that are
going to say things like what I showed
you earlier today which is hilarious and
someone posted to Kamala Harris oh yeah
she said something about the assault
band that shit's important it's
important to have people mock people
like I'm sorry if it hurts someone's
feelings but that shit's important yeah
and I I I think the way that Elon
handled that was great because obviously
you need a specific example to back up
an argument however I sort of think the
whole premise of the conversation is
wrong this idea this war that Twitter is
at with all the think tanks and I think
it was the institute for strategic
discourse that had actually compiled the
information that the BBC guy was talking
about and there is information there
there is data showing you know hate
speech XYZ has has increased however
this is the wrong conversation it's not
the existence or even rise of hate in
the the presence of that content on an
app is not
you're not just trying to ban hate
Banning hate does not stop hate and this
is what the peer-reviewed research shows
so so trying to bully Elon and Twitter
for look even if there was a bump of
hate speech since it became a little bit
more free I mean it seems like that's a
a potentially
understandable
intermediary effect to happen while
things reorient like we open up free
speech we open up the valve a little bit
okay because we think that this is going
to be healthy for Society Long Term
so let it bump a little bit we need that
we need to see what we hate or what
other people hate you need to like what
is it
um free speech let us lets us know who
the idiots are like you you need to
identify them yes yeah yeah the the best
response to whatever it is bad speech is
better speech there's better arguments
and that's you literally have a debate
platform which is what Twitter
essentially is
yeah that is the purpose yeah it's the
purpose yeah yeah and not to mention
that the hate isn't defined so it's only
one type of hate that these people are
typically referring to right wing hate
right wing hey yeah right that's that's
okay and so actually so uh we're we're
suing California we just filed this law
because the uh this uh complaint
they are trying to pass this social
media law called ab587 which
requires it's a censorship law they're
they require these policies on
disinformation misinformation hate
speech and then they use the undefined
use the words extremism and
radicalization there's no definitions
they don't require you to have a a child
exploitation material policy but they do
require you to have a policy on hate
which isn't defined right and so we're
suing them with uh with the Babylon B
and and Temple when did they start this
uh when when they start trying to pass
us
it just went into effect in January so
it's now it's now it's in so if you live
in California what's the repercussions
so it is it's it's targeted at social
media companies okay so basically
mandating that social media companies
um have the submit these policies so we
would have to we would they would force
us to write a policy on hate speech
and submit it to them and then
additionally we would have to on like a
bi-annual basis submit analytics about
all of our moderation data which
honestly we're already transparent about
our moderation data so that's that's
largely public anyway we have a jury
system um and and we have in-house
moderators but the it's it's just it's a
huge burden like it's crazy that they
would expect
companies to submit all that and then
have these arbitrarily well actually not
arbitrarily specifically chosen
categories for policies that are clearly
politically charged and knew some like
when he came out and announced this law
it was very you know we have to stop
hate on social media and misinformation
and disinformation protect
Society protect democracy no you know
you're not protecting democracy by
stopping free speech that is there's no
there's no checks and balances in place
if something turns out to be accurate